they have these social norms around
productivity right now right do more and
less time like how many books are there
out there that tell you like you know
how many more things you can squeeze
into a day and how to be Uber productive
and so we have an unspoken cultural norm
that if you're a productive person
you're a good person if you're not a
productive person you're a bad person
this episode is all about
procrastination and I'm joined by
Professor fuchsia sirwa who is a world
leading expert on the field of
procrastination we talk about all things
relates to procrastination why we
struggle with it the consequences of
procrastination are and what is the
underlying emotional core of
procrastination by definition there is
no such thing as good procrastination
procrastination can never be a good
thing because there's always harmful
consequences attached to we don't
procrastinate because we have no sense
of time we don't procrastinate because
we're lazy it's going to the source and
saying what is the reason you're
pronouncing it we don't procrastinate on
things that are fun even though I've
done loads of research and have written
three of my book chapters about
procrastination just having that
discussion with professor future was
really interesting and I'm actually
gonna go back through the edits in my
book and add in a few bits just to kind
of update it based on this conversation
that we've just had the feeling of being
a bad person because you're not
productive that's what happens when
you're procrastinate I feel ashamed and
I'm procrastinating and so it makes it
difficult to reach out and talk to
people and say I don't really know what
to do here can you lay this task out for
me especially if you've already started
procrastinating but that is the best
thing to do oh by the way if you have a
couple of minutes I would love it if you
could possibly fill in a little survey
we are surveying the audience people who
watch or listen to this podcast and
trying to figure out what are the things
you Vibe with what are the things you
don't who are the sorts of guests that
you'd like to see more of and what sort
of topics should we continue covering on
the Deep Life podcast so if you've got a
couple of minutes it would mean a lot
there's a link in the video description
or in the show notes would love it if
you could help us out and help us make
the podcast better for you guys so yeah
check it out Professor Fisher welcome to
the show thank you so much for coming on
ah my pleasure thanks so much for
inviting me so you are an expert in the
field of procrastination
um and so I wonder if we can start by
defining what is procrastination uh yeah
yes absolutely I think that's a really
great starting point because oftentimes
people
think they are procrastinating and
they're not they're just actually
engaging in one of your kind of garden
variety forms of delay and so
procrastination is a form of delay but
it's very specific type of DeLay So it's
a delay that is unnecessary so it's not
like some family emergency came up and
you put that task aside that you have to
get done done
it's also voluntary so it's not that
somebody told you to stop working on
that and work on something else and it
always involves intention and intended
task that's usually important where you
said I'm going to do this and you might
even have a timeline set with that
intention and so we engage in in that
type of delay either starting the task
or maybe we start and then we don't
complete it and we do that despite
knowing that there's going to be
negative consequences either for
ourselves or for others
and so that I know it sounds as a very
long-winded but it's that's what makes
procrastination a different type of
delay rather than just putting something
aside for for good reasons or because
you were told to
um and you know for a task that really
isn't that important in the first place
got it
um one thing that I think
I think it's in uh Tim pitchell's book
solving the procrastination puzzle the
the idea that there is no such thing as
a good amount of procrastination I
wonder if you if you agree with that I
did yeah well so I think so by the
definition I just said that you engage
in unnecessary voluntary delay in an
intended task despite knowing they'll be
harmful consequences for yourself or
others so if we
um you know are taking that definition
on board by definition there is no such
thing as good procrastination
procrastination can never be a good
thing because there's always harmful
consequences attached to it and what are
some of these harmful consequences
so these range I mean the things that we
think about you know most commonly we
think oh it's going to affect
productivity and and yes it does affects
productivity it affects performance so
numerous Studies have been conducted
with students um over the past few
decades and what we find is that despite
the students saying oh I do my best work
Under Pressure they actually perform
more poorly when they procrastinate so
grades are lower academic cheating and
misconduct is associated with
procrastination in students so those are
the sort of things that we tend to think
about typically the productivity and
academic performance sort of
consequences but what my research has
been looking at over the past two plus
decades is actually the health and
well-being consequences of
procrastination which is not something
we tend to think about we tend to think
of procrastinations as a productivity or
performance issue not something that
actually is going to impact our
well-being and even our physical health
yeah so what are the health and what
like how does procrastination I can I
can imagine it in the sense of you know
I intended to go to the gym yesterday
and then 8 P.M rolled up and it was in
my calendar and it was like you know I'm
feeling a bit low energy today I've got
a bit of a pain in my hand like let me
just I'll just go out for dinner and
have a more relaxing evening does that
is that one of the health consequences
that certainly is one of the health
related
um consequences of procrastination so we
can procrastinate on our health related
tasks like
exercising or starting a diet or
adhering to a diet or even seeking
medical help but that's not it's not
limited to that and I think this is
where it gets really interesting too is
that you know first of all you
understand when we procrastinate we
don't like that we procrastinate it's
not something we go oh I'm so happy I
just procrastinated right we feel bad
about it and we actually feel stressed
because we procrastinate we know that
time is ticking and if we had already a
short period of time to finish a task
especially if it's one where there's a
really clear deadline involved that
stress level is going to go up even more
so and so there's a high degree of
stress and so on the mental health side
what we see is higher levels of anxiety
and depression associated with
procrastination especially chronic
procrastination
and if there's higher levels of stress
we know that stress does not do good
things for the body right it can in the
short run suppress your immune system
and my research has found that even in
young healthy students people students
who chronically procrastinate tend to
experience a higher number of acute
health related issues such as flus and
colds that are related to stress
insomnia aches and pains muscle tensions
strains so on and so forth so there's a
higher degree of illness stress poor
health behaviors poor Medical Care
seeking all of these combined then can
become you know cumulatively can add up
to a recipe for poor health
um
so on the on the point of you know you
mentioned depression anxiety stress
do we have any evidence as to what
direction the causality is now that's a
really good question and I think you
know I think these are Dynamic and
reciprocal and mutually reinforcing
Pathways they have to be
um you know part of that has to do with
sort of the causes of procrastination
which are involved in mood
um and and sort of especially negative
mood which I'll get into shortly but
um you can imagine though that if you're
if you are procrastinating on a regular
basis you're not going to feel good
about yourself you're going to get more
anxious your levels of Stress and
Anxiety go up because you're worried
about the consequences uh handing in
that report late you know of not meeting
the deadline for the job application of
your dream job you know I mean these
sorts of things you're not having that
conversation with a loved one that might
make a huge difference to your
relationship and the consequences of not
telling them some truth maybe they need
to hear so all this things sort of weigh
on us on the background and that can
contribute to the anxiety and and
potentially also the depression but when
you're in an anxious and depressed state
it actually makes you more vulnerable
for procrastination as well too so
you've got I think these bi-directional
Pathways
um so it becomes a sort of vicious cycle
yes very much so and do we see any uh so
we we mentioned the effects of stress in
particular on like the negative physical
effects of stress do we see any negative
physical effects of of like linked with
procrastination that are not mediated by
stress I don't know if that makes sense
yeah no I know what you're saying yeah
so in terms of the physical health
pathway so this is something I've looked
at actually I've tried to see so which
are the pathways so what we know is that
any type of Behavioral tendency right so
if we think about you know not just a
single procrastination instance which
can create some stress right but if we
look at the cumulative effect which is
where most of the evidence is has
focused on to understand these health
effects
um you know over time that stress is
going to add up but over time so can the
poor health behaviors and both of those
will work with each other when we're
feeling more stressed we also tend to
not engage in more Health behaviors and
when we don't engage in the health
promoting behaviors that actually
increases our reactivity to stress
another pathway in there that I didn't
mention is sleep too so people
procrastinate I think I touched on it
with the students they tend to have
higher insomnia but there's numerous
studies that now shown that
procrastination especially chronic
procrastination is linked to poor sleep
sleep and stress get into a vicious
cycle very easily too so the evidence
shows a bi-directional relationship
there and you can imagine with sleep and
feeling too tired unless you and your
example there I'm feeling too tired to
go to the gym right so you didn't maybe
didn't have a good night's sleep so that
gets put off too
um but some of my research has tried to
see which of those Pathways is the most
potent one in understanding the links um
to stress and we we recently published a
study this is with Tim pitchell looking
at students and their stress and health
behaviors and illness over time
um over three time points across the
Academic Year and even though we did
find that procrastination was linked to
poor health behaviors and poor health
and higher stress each time point
when our statistician
Chris went in and looked you know and
sort of a really interesting model to
see let's test all about backwards and
forwards models and see which is the
best Pathways here right and the best
the strongest pathway for explaining
that link was stress that makes sense so
if someone for someone listening to or
watching this right now what are some
questions that they can ask themselves
to see like
is procrastination really a problem in
my life are they I'm imagining there are
there's some sort of procrastination
inventory that psychologists would use
but like what are some questions that
that people might find helpful to answer
for themselves yeah so you're right so
we do have these uh self-report
inventories
um and and typically these are
I mean there's ones that can measure
momentary procrastination like in an
academic setting for example but there's
also ones that get up as I was saying a
behavioral tendency which is more like a
personality trait so we can look at
procrastination or chronic
procrastination or procrastination as a
personality trait by getting people to
you know answer these questions so you
know things like I'm you know I'm I'm
always
um saying uh I'm putting off things and
saying I'll do it tomorrow so you know
these these types of questions as
opposed to we also have the opposite
which is oh when I get a task I try and
take care of it as soon as possible all
right so if you don't agree with that
statement you say no not too often then
that might also put you at a higher
score in terms of assessing your
procrastination or chronic
procrastination level shall we say got
it and so is there presumably there's a
correlation between chronic
procrastination and lack of
conscientiousness as the personality
trait yes yes so it so this
procrastination sort of as a chronic
personality style if you like or behave
behavioral tendency has been linked in
and looked at in relation to these Big
Five personality factors and the two
that was most strongly related to was
conscientiousness negatively but also
neuroticism positively but it's
interesting though it's not
conscientiousness as a whole so it you
know there's there was some initially
some debate well is it just low
conscientiousness you know someone's
just careless and they don't plan things
actually it is just one component of
conscientiousness that tends to be most
strongly related to procrastination
negatively of course again and this is
has to do with the planning component
right but so some of the other the
discipline and all that it's not
actually
um that strongly correlate the most
strong strongest component of
conscientiousness is the one that has to
do with Forward Thinking and planning ah
okay so people who are not very good at
Forward Thinking and planning or tend
not to do it so much also tend to be
procrastinated they tend to be more
prone to procrastination and there's
some good reasons for that too
um so I mean this is where you know Tim
and I about a decade or so ago you know
looked at the existing research and we
formulated this new view of
procrastination as as being what we call
based on sort of an issue of temporal
mood regulation in other words a
prioritization of short-term mood
regulation over long-term goals and the
idea here is that when you have a task
that's unpleasant or difficult or maybe
there's not anything inherently
Difficult about that task but something
about that task triggers within you
self-doubt perfectionism negative
feelings you know basically you're in
the same negative State as if that was a
horrible task it may not actually be a
horrible task it's just your interaction
with that task that makes it feel
horrible to you so that aversiveness of
the task whatever its source and that
relationship with you in the task is
what prompts people procrastinate and so
we see procrastination what we suggest
is procrastination then is a form of
avoidant coping right so if you don't
have kind of that internal good mood
management skills right and you're no
one likes to feel unpleasant right we
don't like anxiety as stress we want to
want to do something right away which is
why we developed you know emotion
regulation skills but if you don't have
a good repertoire of those skills or you
don't you're not you know you maybe that
the intensity of that emotion and
religion that task is too high you might
default to procrastination of a way of
managing that among that those emotions
so that where the prioritization comes
in you now what's priority is the goal
of managing your mood not achieving that
task so you're not thinking about that
task anymore you're thinking about right
now I don't want to feel this way I
don't like this the frustration and the
self-doubt and everything else that's
coming out so you take that task you put
it aside you might even engage in
something more pleasurable and now
you've got immediate mood you know
relief you've just managed your mood
right and that is the essence of
procrastination
but in doing so you're not thinking down
the road you're not thinking about the
consequences you're only thinking about
right now you're prioritizing the goal
of managing your immediate mood over the
goal of achieving your long-term goal um
is that a I mean is is that always a
problem
or is there like a threshold Beyond
which it you'll be like okay I've got
I've got a problem here well okay so I
think I think when we talk about
intensity of things so if something's
really just like I don't know what to do
yeah if you put it aside but if in that
time putting aside you're then trying to
find ways to approach that task so it's
less of an issue for you yeah then
that's different that might be problem
solving that might be initially
procrastination
um and this is where you know it kind of
get we start splitting hairs here a
little bit so if you if you're actually
got I can't deal with that right now
because I'm just too stressed by it yeah
I'm putting it aside I'm gonna take a
breath how can I manage that so now if
you go into problem solving mode see
that's different yep right but that's
not usually what happens when we do that
we usually are just so much you know
reinforced from the the positive relief
we have of not having to deal with that
task because if we put it aside that we
often go on and do other things and and
kind of just forget about it and or we
go hey future me is going to take care
of it future me is going to have all the
self-discipline in the world future me
is going to know how to manage that
stress that I can't manage right now
right future me becomes a superhero at
least in our minds right and that's
future me tomorrow next week next month
whatever the timeline we put it off to
the problem is all we're doing when we
do that is we make future me our Beast
of Burden because the future me now has
to deal with all those unfinished tasks
rushing deadlines and all the other
stress so everything it just gets amped
up hmm
it's quite a quite a stressful place to
be when that happens yeah well this is
why we see such high levels of stress
yeah um and people who chronically
procrastinate
do we have a sense of What proportion of
people struggle with this
so I'm just a great question I think
it's different in different populations
and there's also cultural differences as
well too
um so in the student population it's
been estimated that at least
occasionally 80 to 95 of students
procrastinate so quite frequent but 50
do so chronically no wow that's a lot
that is a lot oh my goodness yeah that's
quite a bit yeah and that's that's our
best guess and estimates and I think one
of the reasons is study so much in
students too is that you know in an
academic setting we have clear
you know guidelines as to when something
should be done it's harder to trap
procrastination when there isn't a clear
deadline or it's an internally set
deadline but that doesn't mean the
procrastination isn't happening so this
is why when you look at adult
populations it can range anywhere from
15 to 25 percent again depending on
where where the study was conducted
um and then you see cultural differences
as well too
um where some cultures are more
forgiving and kind of tolerant of
procrastination and other cultures are
not what sort of cultures are in each in
each camp
so um you know we've done some
International
um research conferences which is great
so we get to see these different
perspectives on on procrastination these
are conferences that are just on
procrastination and I always tell people
we have them every other year because
you know we just can't get around to it
every year but that's not the truth it
takes two years to be able to get enough
evidence to make things new at each in
each conference
um so um some of our colleagues from
South America and Peru basically
procrastination is very much like ah you
know that's okay Manana right like
it's not uh it's more acceptable and you
see it across all levels so
um so there's more tolerance for for it
there and then you see other cultures
um and specifically ones where there
actually is a lot of research going on
on procrastination
um where you can tell the tolerance this
lesson I didn't I didn't recognize this
until one of the procrastination
conferences a couple years back
um and um there were some posters that
students had out and there were some
German colleagues that had the poster
out and they were talking about this
um what they called procrastination
ambulance that was a direct direct
translation it was kind of like this
emergency on Wheels clinic for students
who were distressed by the
procrastination and so they you know
they had sort of a regimen for them to
go through and they had some evidence to
suggest that this regimen that they that
they said you know had the students
engage with helped decrease the
procrastination levels and I remember
with colleague of mine and we were
looking at the main levels of
procrastination at the beginning and at
the end and indeed they had gone down
but the start levels in terms of mean
levels on this this common
procrastination scale that lays General
procrastination scale
the main level that students were so
distressed about in Germany was well
below the North American and the UK
means for for chronic procrastination
suggesting that there's probably less of
a tolerance in places like Germany and
that where punctuality and sort of um
you know sort of sticking to deadlines
is is a little bit more valued
that's interesting
any have you have you seen any research
around sort of like uh South Asian
countries India Pakistan Bangladesh that
sort of thing there was there were some
colleagues um I think the most recent
conference that were presenting um
evidence
um you know it certainly is an issue
there too in in terms of comparing
um mean levels I don't think that's been
done yet but that is I think an
interesting area to look at okay that's
interesting yeah because I one one thing
that's
well one thing that comes to my mind I
don't know I don't know how like
unreasonable this is but sort of uh
propensity to stick to deadlines and
like keep the time like you know in I'm
from Pakistan and it's like if you get
invited to a wedding and it says 3 P.M
everyone's going to be there by like
half past five and the food will be so
it'll say the food's being served at
four but it'll be served at seven and
it's just an accepted part of the
culture yeah yeah and yeah I went to
like one of my English friends weddings
for the first time a couple years ago
and I just had no idea that 12 o'clock
meant like the bride's literally
arriving at 12 oh my goodness wow I'm
the last person here I I you know you
know I rocked up at quarter past
thinking that like everyone's gonna be
an hour and a half late yeah yeah and I
wonder if there's some something there
around kind of Tolerance of
procrastination
um yeah I mean I mean it could be
similarly I think so one of the things
is you know we do sort of look at on the
surface anyways the procrastination
office as a time management issue which
by the way I will say flat out it does
not okay so the evidence on time
management strategies for for managing
procrastination the evidence is
equivocal at best and certainly not long
lasting because it's you know we look at
somebody who's procrastinating they're
not getting their their tasks done on
time right so obviously they can't
manage their time properly right like so
these are sorts of superficial
conclusions that we can come to when we
see someone who's procrastinating so in
terms of deadlines and not meeting them
that I think you know there's some
similar issues but it's not necessarily
the same right so people who
procrastinate aren't necessarily not
punctual right it's a slightly different
issue there it's time both both you know
non-punctuality for example and
procrastination have an element of sort
of temporal thinking involved in them um
but it is it is sort of a different
slightly different kind the fish that
makes sense um so
surely time management is like the first
the first step right so okay so so for
example let's say I'm procrastinating I
like let's I don't know let's use the
gym as an example
if I'd like like for me the first step
if I want to get something done is like
I'll put it on the calendar and it's in
the calendar then I know it's on the
calendar and then if I'm procrastinating
from it while it's on the calendar then
I'll I'll take I'll think okay what's
going on emotionally here but until it's
on the calendar it's it could just be
that I just haven't made the time for it
do you think that's a reasonable
strategy or like what am I what am I
mean okay so I mean I mean there's
different approaches and I guess my
perspective is that you know if you take
that time management and some of these
other approaches you know
um you know self-control these types of
things they're all they're all
approaching the problem from up here at
The Superficial level okay right they're
not actually dressing why right so we
don't procrastinate because we
no sense of time okay we don't
procrastinate
um because we're lazy for example okay I
mean one has nothing to do with the
other people procrastinate get very busy
with all kinds of other things that they
shouldn't be doing threads and the thing
they should be doing which is kind of
clear evidence there I think I'm not
being related to laziness
um but I mean it's it's going to the
source and saying what is the reason
you're procrastinating we don't
procrastinate on things that are fun
right yeah right and procrastinate the
stuff that feels good that's right
procrastinating stops it feels bad stuff
where the mood involved we're having
difficulty we're struggling with it a
difficult task related emotions and so
the first step then if you want to be
effective is to actually look at those
tasks those emotions why you know you
could probe and say okay first I think
first is what are you feeling
right and is it something about the task
which then maybe you can rearrange or
reframe the task to make it less
unpleasant right
or how you look at the task to make it
less unpleasant or is it something about
you right is it something that's
bringing up old feelings from the past
um that are uncomfortable is it bringing
up insecurities is it bringing up
self-doubt is it bringing up you know
perfectionistic Tendencies and fear of
failure and all these other things right
and so that's the place to start because
once you start becoming aware of those
then you can start to manage those
feelings and and use the strategies that
are appropriate for managing the
different different emotions involved
too time management is a Band-Aid
solution it's not going to actually
solve your problem and if it's something
a deeper issue then you're going to
continue to procrastinate anytime you
encounter that task no matter how much
you know you could actually get tied up
in writing to-do lists and spending all
this time blocking off your calendar
instead of doing the thing that you're
supposed to do fooling yourself into
thinking that you're actually managing
it when in fact you're not
this episode is very kindly brought to
you by huel I've been a pen customer of
huel since my fifth year of medical
school since 2017 actually since before
I started my YouTube channel and I first
started using heal because my life was
pretty hectic I was juggling lots of
different things like medical school and
exams and trying to sort out publication
points for my future like doctor job
applications and alongside I was running
a business I was building an app and I
was trying to maintain some semblance of
a social life and so he actually came in
really handy for that if you haven't
heard of it it's basically a meal in a
shake that contains all of the
ingredients that are essential to thrive
it's got a perfect balance of protein
and carbs and fats and vitamins and
minerals and these days the heel black
edition is my absolute favorite comes in
nine flavors salted caramel is my
personal favorite and the heel black
edition is particularly good because it
is a higher protein version than the
huel original it was the original that I
was using back in 2017 but the Black
Edition came out a few years ago changed
the game because it's 40 grams of
protein for 400 calories I'm trying to
get hinge and so I'm keeping an eye on
like my protein intake and it's so nice
that I can get that high protein hit as
the first thing in the morning heel is
also very affordable it comes comes out
to one pound 68 per meal for a 400
calorie meal which is actually way
cheaper than most of the other options
on the market and certainly way cheaper
than other you know even Standalone
protein shakes like I said I've been a
pain customer of huel since 2017. my
friends literally make fun of me as to
how much fuel I have in the house and
they're like what you have all this
healed I'm like yeah it's actually so
good so if you're interested in signing
up for heal then head over to heel.com
forward slash Deep dive and if you use
that URL a it helps us out because then
they're Keen to sponsor more episodes
but B you get a completely free t-shirt
and a free Shaker with your order so
that is hopefully an incentive to use
fuel.com forward slash Deep dive and
actually I interviewed the founder of
huel Julian Hearn on this very podcast
in the very first season so you can
check out that episode if you like it's
got rave reviews really good episode all
about starting and growing a business so
anyway thank you so much heal for
sponsoring this episode this episode is
very kindly brought to you by
trading212. now people ask me all the
time for advice about investing because
I've made a bunch of videos about it on
the YouTube channel and my advice for
most people is generally invest in Broad
stock market index funds which is
exactly what you can do completely for
free with trading 212. it's a great app
that lets you trade stocks and funds and
ETFs and foreign exchange if you really
want to and one of the great things
about the app is that if you're new to
the world of investing you can actually
invest with fake money you don't have to
put real money in they've got a practice
mode where you invest fake money and
then it actually tracks what the market
is doing in real time so you can see had
I invested 100 pounds into this thing
what would my return have been X weeks
or X months further down the line once
you've got some comfort with that then
it's super easy to deposit money into
your trading tube into account you can
use Apple pay like I do initially or you
can use a direct bank transfer and then
once the money is in your trading 212
account then you can invest it in
basically whatever you want the other
really cool feature about trading 212 is
their pies feature so what you can do is
you can follow people who've created
investing pies for example someone might
have a pie where I don't know 30 of its
apple and 20 is Tesla and 10 is the S P
500 and you can follow people on the app
and see what pies they've created and
you can see the performance of those
pies and then you can just copy and
paste a particular pie into your own
account and so that means like let's say
you've got 100 pounds to invest and
you've put 50 of it into the S P 500 but
you want to be a little bit more
experimental with the other 50 pounds
you can invest it into a pie where
someone else is generally a pro or
someone in their bedroom who just loves
the markets has already done all the
homework for you also very excitingly
there's a new feature that they've added
to the app which is a daily interest on
your uninvested cash these interest
rates may go up or down over time as the
economic environment changes but the
cool thing is that you get paid out
every single day if you're into that
sort of thing and so if you haven't yet
started with investing and you want to
give it a go then you can download the
app on the App Store and if you use the
coupon code Ali Ali it will give you a
totally free share worth up to 100
pounds it's available on iPhone and
Android and you can check it out by
typing in trading212 into your
respective App Store so thank you so
much trading212 for sponsoring this
episode would it be fair to say that all
of these emotions link to fear in some
way or is that too much of an
oversimplification no I mean I think I
mean fear is often involved that's a
very strong emotion
um sometimes you know I think it they
trigger our different fears but you know
I mean this gets more into sort of a
philosophical sort of area in terms
we're talking about what's at the root
of all emotions and negative emotions
right sometimes it's sadness right
um and you know that might be a
different type of emotional experience
right
um and so you just don't and you might
experience that as a deep motivation I'm
just not motivated to do this because it
it triggers a deeper sadness and you
maybe something where you're like why am
I doing this at all or what's the
purpose in my life or you know like so
that's not fear-based per se right yeah
so I think it can be a full range and
often it's a complex range and and and
some of the research that
um
um one of my four PhD students did also
suggest that it can sometimes be mixed
sometimes we can be both excited about a
task and kind of like oh I can't wait to
do this and really prove myself and at
the same time fearful or anxious or
nervous about that task and depending on
how we manage that balance you know and
and I think one of the things that some
of the research has shown that people
are prone to procrastination are more
sensitive to those negative emotions
areas of the brain the amygdala which is
sort of the threat detection center
right
um those air that area of the brain is
qualitatively different in people who
are prone to procrastination versus
those that are not suggesting against uh
sensitivity to negative stimuli and that
includes the negative emotions that they
have around a task
yeah I definitely want to talk more
about this emotional stuff
um is to what extent is uh uncertainty
or a lack of clarity about the goal or
the task to what extent is that does
that come into it because that strikes
me a slightly different to the emotion
stuff no actually it's it's linked right
into it oh is it yeah good one like I
was going to get to that thank you no
yeah so I mean so think about it right
if you have a task that's not well
structured it's uncertain what do you
feel
um
[Music]
uh uncertainty
uh anxiety stress yeah like I'm not
really sure I'm not really sure it's a
big mountain it's like study chemistry
what a study like oh it's the Xbox too
big it's emotions yeah
okay it's not just thoughts right so we
can think about things in a way that
trigger the emotions right it's not
necessarily that the emotions are coming
first but the way we think about a task
or even the way a task is is laid out to
us so going back to where I said okay
you know what's the first thing to do
we'll probe the emotions what do you
feel I'm feeling a bit overwhelmed by
this task because it's so big and it's
so uncertain there's so many moving
Parts I have no idea if I'm making
progress or where to begin so that then
would identify that something about that
task is not clear enough right to allow
you to engage with it in a way that
doesn't invoke these these feelings of
uncertainty and stress and anxiety and
self-doubt and everything yeah right and
so then okay right let's get some
clarity ask somebody what do I need to
do can you lay this out can you give me
sort of a little bit more you know
detail and this happens often with tasks
that are that are new to us that we're
not done before we have no clue we can
relate to them to things we've done
before but then again there's always
that that sort of gnawing uncertainty
that is this really what I should be
doing right and so getting clarity
around the task getting structured
around the tasks that brings down all
those emotions and even though it might
be the first time doing it yeah okay
it's a little bit of uncertainty but I
can manage that little bit of
uncertainty versus that large amount of
uncertainty because I don't have a clue
at all
so that's a really good place to start
yeah so what sort of things can people
do to like if if let's say someone
listening to this is about to embark on
a thing and they're like they recognize
oh
uncertainty is involved here what are
some ways to sprinkle in more clarity
into the task so I think first of all
getting information talking to other
people
um and this is often a tough one
especially if someone's prone to
procrastination is found themselves
procrastinating because of task
uncertainty
um because there's a lot of Shame around
procrastination and a lot of guilt
around procrastination so even though we
might have that immediate mood relief
though we know the task is still sitting
there and we realize that you know we
feel bad that we should be doing it but
I think the other thing too that I
hadn't spoken about is that you know we
have we have these social norms around
productivity right now right right do
more and less time like how many books
are there out there that tell you like
you know how many more things you can
squeeze into a day and how to be Uber
productive and you know all these this
this type of culture now that really
values productivity and so we have an
unspoken cultural norm that if you're a
productive person you're a good person
if you're not a productive person you're
a bad person and those Norms that that
what we call you know the feeling of
being a bad person because you're not
productive that's what happens when you
procrastinate they're triggered you know
okay I'm going against what Society
expects of me right I feel ashamed and
I'm procrastinating and so it makes it
difficult to reach out and talk to
people and say I don't really know what
to do here can you lay this task out for
me especially if you've already started
procrastinating but that is the best
thing to do and I think this is where
um you know we're talking about
procrastination and sort of managing it
a little bit too and where to start with
things is we also we need to be aware
that being hard on people when they
procrastinate or anything that induces
that guilt or that shame is only going
to make people make it worse make people
procrastinate more so we need to have an
open culture where people can come and
ask
questions without feeling judged yeah
you know and without feeling that that's
no you shouldn't you should just know
what you're doing even though you've
never done this before right absolutely
yeah so I think yeah reaching out and
asking for help first off or you know
right when the task is put in front of
you make sure you've got that Clarity
talk to the person
um this is actually I think one of the
reasons why there was not that many
studies that went on but there was a
couple of studies that looked at
procrastination levels during the
pandemic and there was a bit of a spike
and one of the reasons I suspect there's
other reasons
um relating to sort of background stress
levels but I think one of the reasons
too in a work environment is that
everyone was remote right so if you're
in an office and you've got this task
and you're like I don't know what to do
right you just walk over and you talk to
somebody hey I'm not really sure what
I'm doing here the first time I've had
to write this sort of report and my
structure in the right way where you get
advice on the spot
what happens when everybody's remote you
can't just jump in on a zoom thing and
you know ask them you could try and
email them but it's a lot harder to get
that instant advice and so a lot of
people were left with doing things and
feeling a lot of uncertainty on top of
all the uncertainty of living during a
really dangerous time you know in terms
of people's you know security with their
health and their well-being and their
Economic Security and variety of other
things social connections being cut off
so
um yeah anyways I've gone off on a
tangent there no that's so interesting I
think yeah just actually getting Clarity
on on what the task is what the goal is
I find it useful to understand like the
why behind the goal because often like a
manager or someone will give us a task
and they'll have a lot of context in
their mind but without the context it's
easy to go down the wrong route or think
I'm not sure why I'm doing this and yeah
yeah yeah so that yeah so that's a
really really important um starting
place is to make sure you've got you've
got some clarity you know exactly
or have at least enough of an idea and
you and you've got the information you
need too yeah right so you might hey
might say oh this is the structure of
stats but if you don't have all the
information to help you complete those
steps you're going to get to that spot
where you go I don't share what I'm
doing now anymore yeah right you know so
you can have Clarity at the beginning
and then making sure you've got the
resources and the information available
to you so that if you reach a point
where there's a less amount of clarity
about what you're doing you can actually
have those resources to to help guide
you nice yeah
um I mean for for context like this
might be it might be interesting for you
to hear um so I'm writing one of these
uh productivity books which I finished
yesterday
handed to the copy editor uh the title
is feel good productivity and the middle
three chapters are about procrastination
and
um prompted by
um my reading of some of Tim's work
which I suspect is also some of your
work just sort of really leaning into
this emotional side of procrastination
and so the first chapter in the
procrastination section is about
uncertainty and so the solution is
Clarity the second chapter we're still
not entirely sure what to call it
initially it was called it was about
anxiety or it was it was really trying
to get it like the emotional side and
this was I think at one point we called
the chapter fear and sometimes at some
point we called it negative emotion and
so we're still trying to figure out the
naming of that middle chapter but then
the final chapter in the procrastination
section is um about overcoming inertia
and just getting started like taking
that next action step just doing the
thing for five minutes because once
you've gotten started with something
it's generally easier to continue going
but it's that middle middle bit that's
like trying to address all of the
emotions but like in a pithy sounding
chapter title does anything come to mind
while we're here yeah I mean just yeah
difficult difficult emotions I mean I
mean yeah then that's what they are
they're difficult we struggle with them
right
um yeah but I mean I would I mean that
sounds great I would argue though even
though you've put um you know
uncertainty that's still emotion yeah
right yeah um and even at the end just
you know I know that's Tim's favorite
thing just just go like you know
motivation follows action not the other
way around um but
um what that does is short circuits all
the thoughts that can stir up right yes
the negative emotions
um and so you're still addressing the
emotions when you do that because you
don't give your chance yourself a chance
to basically start going well what if I
don't get it right and what happens if
it's not perfect and oh I'm never going
to do this and so and and those types of
ruminative or procrastinatory you know
types of thoughts they die dial up the
negative emotions that are just going to
push you further away from that task so
they are still tapping into that same
edge of the ground yeah and that's why I
you know well Tim and I say like that is
that for me that's Ground Zero nice
everything about procrastination Ground
Zero is difficult emotions that we
struggle with interesting okay for
different reasons
uh so in in my introduction to part two
which is the procrastination chapter of
the the procrastination three chapters
um I have a
I'm just gonna if it's all right with
you I'll just like run you through my
method and you can tell me what you
agree with and what you potentially
disagree with because we still have like
a month to make the final changes oh
okay so
um the way that I've I'm I'm trying to
introduce this is that we all we all
have these things that we that we that
we struggle to do and Society tells us
that the solution is like a bunch of
different options so option number one
is motivation this is you know if if you
wanted it enough you would do it just
like if you want if you wanted that
thing more than you wanted to breathe
then you'd find a way to make it happen
where there's a will there's a way blah
blah blah yeah no pain no gain yeah all
of that
um and then the but the the issue with
motivation is that it waxes and wanes
sometimes I feel very motivated to go to
the gym other times I don't and so if
I'm pegging my going to the gym on
motivation it's not particularly
sustainable so then some people would
say well
the problem is that you're relying on
motivation instead of relying on
motivation rely on discipline and
willpower grit and persistence and all
of those things and you'll get like Navy
Seals being like discipline equals
Freedom like you know you just gotta and
it's a very sort of warmongering almost
like yeah battle language around
discipline
um but then what I'm kind of trying to
propose or slash explain in these three
chapters is
there's there's a third method and you
know we're kind of calling it The
unblock method it's like figure figure
out what are the blockers that are
blocking you from doing the task and
address the blockers and then a at least
you'll know what it is and B you won't
have to rely on motivational discipline
maybe there's a little bit of discipline
just take that that in that that next
action step but it's discipline it's
more doses rather than the entire
strategy and so we're saying that the
three blockers are uncertainty anxiety
and inertia and if you address them one
at a time fundamentally you're
addressing the underlying hopefully the
thing that's blocking you how does that
land for you
yeah I mean I think that that sounds all
right I again I'm I'm you know I'm very
I'm very situated in sort of like and
because I've looked at all the research
and even the brain Imaging research and
it all supports you know this view which
is it's emotions first underneath so
what's blocking you yeah but so that's
true so you can move roadblocks but how
did that lock up get there in the first
place
right yeah right so what brought that
block into being yeah it was the
negative emotion the emotions and
something about the task something about
yourself and I say it's a it's an it's
an interaction between you and the task
oh nice yeah so is that that interaction
between you and the task it gives rise
to these negative emotions that then
creates blockages right
so you know
um you can start telling yourself that
oh it's not the perfect time and I've
got to be more motivated and that's
where sort of the inertia kind of kicks
in but that we we keep ourselves stuck
in that inertia through the thoughts
that keep stirring up these negative
emotions
um anxiety and fears there but there can
be other types of emotions too and
certainly that hits closer
um you know to the core what was your
the first one again uncertainty yeah
yeah but that's that so that's more
about the the aspects of the tasks right
yeah um so something about the tasks
that soliciting the Motions the second
one is more about something within
yourself that's coming up yeah and then
the last one is more of a okay so stop
doing things that keep stirring up these
emotions and just get on with it right
so you've got to just short circuit that
pathway
um and and engage the positive emotions
and that's what that last strategy does
is you're engaging the positive emotions
um you know we've done some research to
show that that actually it's not just
high levels of negative emotions or
difficult emotions that drive
procrastination it's also low levels of
positive emotions right so if you know
we had a study where we had students who
had to study over a 48-hour period and
we have adults who are trying to trying
to make um you know healthy changes in
their life over six month period in both
instances what we found is that a people
who are prone to procrastinate were less
likely to achieve their goals big
surprise there but they also not just
felt more frustrated and found their
their their you know their goal
um Less Pleasant but they found it less
enjoyable so there's lower levels of
positive emotions and those positive
emotions that that link between seeing
this isn't doesn't make me happy enough
right was Amplified if in the presence
of Temptations
especially social Temptations okay nice
yeah so if there was something and you
can see it's a relative thing here's
this task have to do which I rate really
low in terms of how pleasant and how fun
and enjoyable is going to be here's this
other thing that looks really super
enjoyable and it's going to look even
more enjoyable relative to this task so
relative to that your task starts
looking less and less Pleasant and then
you're gonna be like I'm not feeling
good about this task and it doesn't look
like it's going to bring me any Joy so I
want to go to the things that's going to
bring me joy right and of course they
procrastinate hmm
one um
one thing I've often heard in this
context is well
some of us just have to do things that
we don't like like I don't like paying
my taxes I don't like paying the bills
but I've just got to do it like how does
that fit into your
yeah and I mean I mean this is the thing
I mean most of us will go out and for
certain tasks we we have to do it and we
just do but in in those instances I
would say just a couple of things going
on
um you've realized that you can manage
those feelings you have confidence in
your ability to manage those feelings
perhaps because you have a good
repertoire of emotion regulation skills
right you're able to find some humor in
it right you're able to reframe it in a
way
um that's not just unpleasant but that
actually is Meaningful you know and one
of my foreign PhD students she did a
really nice experiment to show quite
clearly that when you ask people to
frame a tasks that they were at risk for
procrastinating in a more meaningful way
compared to someone who was just told to
write something about the task and she
followed up with them I think it was
like 36 to 48 hours later they
procrastinated on average two hours less
just from writing out this task is
important
um you know valuable to me because this
task is important for my connecting to
others people because has this task is
important for my personal growth because
simple things just finding that
meaningfulness was enough to actually
reduce that that tendency to
procrastinate
some people just have a good you know
um range of skills or good or well
practicing managing those difficult
emotions they might might engage in this
sort of meaning making for example
um or they might you know find other
ways to look at the task in a different
way so that it feels less stressful to
them
um but I think the other thing we need
to consider and this is something that
I've just um you know recently written a
paper about
um and I think it's again comes on the
heels of the pandemic and some of that
research showing that people
procrastinate more is that sometimes
though if we you know if we think about
procrastination as a coping method for
dealing with these difficult task
related emotions right
um
what happens when you know you're in a
situation where you've got a whole bunch
of other things to cope with like a
pandemic and the health of yourself and
your family your financial well-being
and job insecurity and uncertainty of
when this thing's going to end and all
this sort of thing so that's going to
eat up all your coping resources or most
of them and now you've got those nasty
report that you've never written before
you're not uncertainty you don't know
what you're doing you can't go over and
ask somebody at the desk because you're
working remotely and what are you going
to do
well quick and easy dirty method Works
you're going to procrastinate it right
you've just manage your mood and you've
saved you know you know basically
protected those coping resources as
limited coping resources you have to
deal with all the other big background
stuff
um and that's I think the other thing we
have to think about too sometimes we may
find ourselves procrastinating because
there's a lot of background stress going
on in our lives and it just becomes a
convenient way although albeit not a
great way of dealing with things
um and you know from that perspective I
think that's where we need to be
compassionate both to ourselves and
others when we see them struggling with
procrastination maybe there's something
else going on in the background of their
life it's not you know strict discipline
do this and just get on with it there's
you know it's so many people do this and
there's a reason we do it and it's
instantly rewarding it's convenient
especially in circumstances where there
is a lot of background stress and I
think
we have to kind of get out of seeing it
as a character flaw and instead see it
as just simply part of Being Human what
if any is the role of discipline in this
like what is discipline like from a just
like quality professor's perspective and
what's the role in getting things done
yeah I mean so I think this we often
kind of conflate discipline with um
self-control or willpower even and these
are these are you know willpower now
we're getting into the realm of
philosophy right
you know what is willpower where does
what is the will what is this power that
come from that allows us to sort of move
forward on things and
um I think you know with discipline one
way of looking at discipline is that you
know you set up habits for yourself and
you stick to those habits so it has to
do with sort of adhering to a set of
guidelines
more generally speaking
um willpower is slightly different
because it it I you know and and this is
something that is hotly contested I I
remember one evening I sat with a
colleague of mine and he was like how
come there's no studies on Willpower
it's like how do we even Define it in
the first place how are we going to
measure this thing it's just this sort
of entity that we understand is existing
as somehow you should just do it and
bring yourself forward yeah
um and I think again discipline all this
you know from a psychological
perspective is probably the closest
construct happening to do with
self-control being able to self which
includes being able to self-regulate
which includes being able to
self-regulate your emotions right so
it's not just emotions but thoughts and
behaviors Etc
um but again I would say that that is
another layer on top of it right so we
can talk about Ground Zero for
procrastination as being some difficulty
in managing emotions right
and all of us like you said we all
encounter tasks that are difficult some
people have they bring they might either
have less less
higher tolerance for those negative
emotions perhaps combined with greater
practice and capacity to then just say
yeah this is uncomfortable but I'm gonna
I'm gonna push myself through it that's
where the self-control comes in yep
right um so it's it's an asset it's a
resource you can draw upon when you're
struggling with those emotions and I
always try and make that clear because
you often see well people with poor
self-control procrastinate well yes of
course because they're not they're
they're not easily just giving up on you
know managing those emotions they're
struggling and working through they're
keeping that that focus and they're also
you know the same areas of the brain
that has to do with self-control or also
in prefrontal cortex and that also are
involved in
similar regions anyways to being able to
think ahead and thinking about the
consequences of our actions we often
think of the opposite of self-control as
being impulsivity right so we can't
control we just follow our impulses
wherever they go impulse shopping and
pulse eating you know
um
but you know so so we think of that as
being undisciplined right or poor
self-control
um and you know there there's there's
some
um you know some researchers suggest
that you know all procrastination is
just impulsivity well it's like impulse
being impulsive doesn't cause you to
procrastinate because if that was true
you procrastinate on even things that
were fun yeah true right so what
impulsivity does what layers over you've
got this task that's difficult you're
struggling with the emotions you don't
know how to manage them instead of
staying focused on how can I manage
these emotions if you're more impulsive
you're going to be more easily
distracted by things within the
environment that will offer you a quick
emotional fix right and that's where the
impulsivity comes in so it facilitates
Justice digital distractions and so many
other things in the environment do the
facilitates procrastination but does not
cause it per se
an image that's coming to my mind is
that it's if if emotions are Ground Zero
for procrastination it's almost like the
emotions are sort of the the the hump we
have to get over to get started with a
task that's right and for some people
their level of discipline is or the or
the level of self-control is higher than
that hump and so they can be like you
know what the hump's there but like I'm
sufficiently self-controlled to get over
the hump but for other people the
self-control level is below where the
hump is yeah and so the only option
there is to then actually try and reduce
the size of the hump by addressing the
emotions and getting yeah developing the
skills of emotional regulation yeah
that's a cool way to visualize it I
think you know I mean and and that's
just it if you've got that greater
degree of self-control you can sit with
those emotions and work through them and
struggle through them because you're
you're not going to be wanting to just
avoid right self-control helps reduce
the tendency to avoid things
um and including that those negative
emotional um experiences and and focuses
you in on okay what do I need to do to
manage these emotions right so it also
helps you kind of say here's the problem
I need to solve yeah right and it's
still problem doesn't make problem go
away and and again it could be as simple
as oh I've just got to look at this task
this way and find a meaningful thing of
it or if I rearrange this task this way
it's actually not that stressful overall
um the other thing that can happen
though too and this is like sort of
going back to the ground serious
emotions and I think it's a really good
example of it is often we procrastinate
not because of the emotions we're
experiencing right now with that task
they might actually be fairly manageable
yeah but because of the emotions that we
imagine
that we're going to experience once we
start engaging with the task
so ah okay yep you know have you ever
been in that situation before where
you've had something you're like I I
don't I don't know what this is I've not
done it before oh boy this is going to
be really hard this is going to be
really stressful I think when I start
doing this I'm just going to get so
frustrated I'm just going to want to
give it a uh I'm not even going to start
it right yeah so that is actually that's
an interesting phenomena emotionally
because now what we're doing is we're
sort of time traveling and we're doing
some emotional time traveling as well
and we're picturing ourselves in the
future with this task and trying to you
know
um
sort of
simulate what our emotional experiences
are going to be
big problem with that right that by the
way is that that particular phenomenon
is called effective forecasting and the
problem with that is that numerous
scientific Studies have shown that as
human beings we're terrible at actually
being able to predict
um accurately our emotional states we
tend to see those emotional states as
being way more intense than what they're
going to be and Lasting way longer than
what they're going to be too and so that
becomes a bit of an issue as well as I
call making emotional mountains out of
mole Hills right yeah like it's usually
not that bad once you get started but
it's easy to convince yourself it's
going to be really bad yeah yeah but
that's but what we're doing is we're
experiencing those emotions we're time
traveling ahead and thinking that those
emotional states are going to be really
difficult and and they never really are
mostly because we forget about something
that I really love the label of this we
forget about our emotional immune system
oh yeah so which is this idea that when
we're in a difficult situation we
naturally bring to bear a number of
internal external coping resources so we
might bring our sense of humor in to
deal with it we might know you know you
know call a friend kind of thing and
those coping resources which is part of
our sort of emotional
um immune response if you like help
bring down the intensity and the
duration of those emotional experiences
that we might have when we're struggling
with the task but we forget about our
emotional immune system because we don't
have the context we're sort of seeing a
sliver of time with this task and we
forget about all the contextual elements
around it that are going to be there to
actually support us and make it actually
not anywhere near half as bad as what
we're imagining it to be
um I'd love to move on to talking about
the things that we can do if we're
struggling with procrastination but one
question before we go there
um is there any evidence that we
struggle more with procrastination later
in the day
um I guess I'm thinking of like the
whole ego depletion thing and like the
controversy around that like if you've
just had a if you've just had a high
glucose meal you're less likely to do
hey yeah yeah the whole fatigue thing
yeah so there's still a lot of
controversy around that that ego
depletion and whether it is actually a
thing and and I don't I think I think um
that's not something I would I
personally you know as a yeah
psychological scientist would say is is
a thing that actually comes into play I
think fatigue
um can certainly make it easier right so
if you think about if you've got
something to struggle with these
emotions and you're tired right to cope
you're going to put it aside right but I
don't think we can assume that everyone
feels more tired later in the day right
because there has been some work done on
morningness and evening eveningness
um and some people are more tired
earlier in the day and More Alive later
in the day
um the different diurnal Rhythms on that
so I think it has more to do with an
individual you know diurnal rhythms of
of when you you know feel more energized
in that if you are more depleted in that
it's going to be easier to put something
aside but are you actually when you're
doing that I would ask are you actually
procrastinating or are you just making a
wise choice that you know what I'm too
tired to do a good job on this right now
yeah um and so I'm going to put it aside
but first thing tomorrow morning I'm
gonna get up and do it and you get up
the next morning and you do it that's
actually not procrastinating yeah unless
it's good time management I guess well
yeah well yeah just it just it's just a
prioritization of your goals and your
energy levels and everything yeah
this episode is brought to you by
Shopify now this is very exciting
because we have been a pain customer of
Shopify for the last several years we
use Shopify to handle the website and
also the back end of essentially which
is our kind of stationary line and we're
also using Shopify as the front end and
the back end for a new tech brand that
we're now building out and if you
haven't heard of it Shopify is an
incredible platform that lets you
basically sell anything online and also
in person it's an e-commerce platform
that powers businesses of all sizes from
really tiny businesses all the way to
multi-billion Dollar Enterprises and
even though Shopify is really well set
up to power businesses at enormous scale
they've also got a bunch of features
that are really helpful for complete
beginners or people new to starting a
business for example they've got the
business name generator which is a free
tool that you can use to figure out a
name for your business they've got their
starter plant which is a very cheap and
easy way to actually start selling
things online and they've got a bunch of
free online courses on their Shopify
learn platform and those courses give
you access to the collective knowledge
and experience of loads of successful
entrepreneurs from all around the world
so if that stands up your street then
head over to shopify.com forward slash
deep dive which is also in the video
description and the show notes and that
will let you sign them to a totally free
trial that will let you see if you Vibe
with Shopify as much as we do so thank
you so much Shopify for sponsoring this
episode there's that whole theory around
um eat that frog you know if you're
struggling with something just do it
first thing in the morning and then
you'll have it out of the way the whole
Mark between thing yeah it's it's it's
fairly old school but it's yeah what are
your thoughts on that theory
um I you know works for some doesn't
work for others right because if you're
someone who is prone to procrastination
and you know your emotion regulation
skills are more precarious or more taxed
or less developed or you're less
confident about them taking on the big
thing it could be just the thing that
triggers you to go no way I can't do
this it's just too much you can't you
can't manage those feelings and you may
need just to step into things with
smaller things first to build the
confidence right
um and and build that that sense that
yeah I am actually doing things which is
why you know taking a large task
building in into small bits you know
that they always say well that works
because it builds your confidence
it does that but more importantly what
it does is it takes away the stress yeah
right large tasks that are overwhelming
seem stressful breaking into small bits
takes it down to less stressful
manageable bite and so for some people
that strategy works I would say that
others can go in and do the hard thing
first you know that's that that's kind
of like not sitting and letting those
thoughts sort of drum up all those
emotions and those people probably have
higher levels of self-control as well so
they're probably less prone to be
procrastinating in the first place
anyways
so um what are some of the most
effective strategies that you've come
across for overcoming procrastination
um so there's a couple of different
approach
um I think if it's something to do with
task as we talked about getting Clarity
on tasks that are uncertain if the task
is too big and and isn't structured well
give it some structure break the task
down into small pieces so all these
things can kind of bring down and
creates those you know potentially High
negative or difficult emotions that
might prompt you to procrastinate
um I think there's other dynamics that
go on too especially once we start
procrastinating that are really good to
kind of be aware of and and to and in
terms of when you're trying to manage
the procrastination and and so you know
how you see the task obviously the
meaningfulness we just spoke about
that's a really effective strategy
um that that can certainly help
but I think when you're dealing with the
task is more especially with the
emotions and you're really struggling
with those emotions
um an important thing is to actually
um you know not be so hard on yourself
like don't do anything that's going to
generate more negative emotions or throw
more layers of negative difficult
emotions onto something that you're
already procrastinating because you've
got difficult motions anywhere in there
in the first place right
um so a couple key strategies and again
it depends on whether you've already
procrastinated or if you're you're
struggling with a task right so if
you're if you're struggling with the
task
um it would say that self-compassion is
an effective strategy and that's
basically recognizing that you know
um to struggle with things part of a
learning process as part of Being Human
not getting it right on the first time
you know and that's often people we
still they start things and then they
realize oh it's not going the way I
planned right
um and that's when they can abandon it
because they've made a mistake and the
perfectionism kicks in and everything
that's when you need to be
self-compassionate um and so
self-compassion kicks in when we're
struggling with our own personal
feelings shortcomings difficults
thoughts about ourselves and the tasks
Etc and and basically it's just being
kind rather than critical rather than
saying what's wrong with me why can't I
get this right you know right
um and recognizing that this is
something that everybody does and people
are tending to be critical but also they
all struggle and that's just part of
being human and then not getting over
identified with those negative emotions
right keeping them in a mindful balance
state so that you're not sort of
overcome and just sort of sucked into
that Vortex of negative emotions which
you know can be really really difficult
to get out
um
and the thing with um you know the
self-compassionate response there too is
it it it's not people have a hard time
with it because they think it's like
giving a free pass for procrastinating
um they think it means self-indulgence
or you know there's studies looking at
this the the difficulties that people
have and why they think you know
self-compassion is not a great thing
actually what the science says is that
it will motivate you right people who
don't waste time you know just whipping
up more of those negative motions and
instead say yeah I procrastin you know
I'm struggling with this task and I'm at
risk for procrastinating it but you know
what I'm not going to get caught up in
that I'm just going to focus on what I
need to do and kind of keep
um going ahead and being kind and
changing that internal dialogue right
like things we say to ourselves when
we're you could never say that to a
friend like when you go oh what's wrong
with you why can't you get this done you
wouldn't say that to a good friend or
someone you cared about but we so easily
say that to ourselves right and that
really just does doesn't help anybody
and doesn't help ourselves this makes it
more likely we're gonna continue to
procrastinate and you know same thing
applies if you have started to
procrastinate right being
self-compassionate to your
procrastination you're not the first
person to procrastinate nor will you be
the last there's nothing particularly
special about your procrastination so
get over it you know just cut the drama
right and just kind of get on with
things right figure out what you need to
do right but self-forgiveness has also
been shown at least a couple of studies
to be effective so you know it was one
study where you know they asked students
about students who procrastinate
studying for an exam and they asked them
to the extent to which they forgave
themselves they followed up with them a
couple weeks later and those who forgave
themselves procrastinate less and the
reason they procrastinate less is their
level of negative emotions went down
around the task yeah right so those are
what's back down to the emotions it
comes back it all comes back to us
Ground Zero okay that was Ground Zero it
is
[Laughter]
um what are your thoughts on uh
easy versus challenging goals as it
relates to procrastination
so I mean this this is where it kind of
gets tricky though too and I think this
for me I always think about that um I
mean there's a couple different things
ways and and maybe maybe I'm not
completely understanding the question
but
um
you know we can always take a goal
that's challenging and reframe it in a
way that's less challenging yeah to make
it easier and I think that that's part
of you know the mental work that we can
do before we start that's part of the
Preparatory
um
um stuff before we engage with that task
um I also think though that easy tasks
um tend to be the ones we use to
procrastinate on the more challenging
tasks right so if we've got a bunch of
little things we have to do right and we
know there's this big pressing task and
it really does need to be done it's
going to take some time and it's going
to take some challenge but we decide not
to engage with that instead do all these
little things well what are we doing
right well we're procrastinating the big
task which was the important one and
we're doing all these little things and
we're feeling like hey look see I'm not
lazy I'm productive right we're
countering those social norms that we're
afraid we're so afraid that we're going
to be transgressing by procrastinating
right and now going oh look see I'm a
productive person look at all the stuff
I'm doing yeah but what you're doing
really isn't important right
um and so we can fool our ourselves into
thinking that we're also getting a sense
of confidence we're getting a little bit
of a mood boost so that's a very kind of
I find that a very particularly tricky
um way to well it's not it's a clever
way to deal with procrastination but
it's a tricky thing to break out of
because you're getting some other types
of rewards that are not so apparent for
the procrastination and and you can go
on fooling yourself that you're being
really super productive and that you're
not procrastinating and being complete
denial of the fact that yeah but there's
this thing over here that you're
supposed to be doing you're not really
doing it
yeah absolutely
um have you have you come across
anything around input goals versus
outcome goals
by which I mean like uh the outcome of
uh hit the X revenue for my business
which is somewhat outside of my control
because it's like based on other people
giving me money versus I will make 50
sales calls a day I'll focus on the
thing that's within my control rather
than focusing on the outcome that's
outside of my control yeah so I think
that that that aligns with some of the
research that's been done on on whether
the goals are autonomous or not yeah
right so if a goal is feels more
controlled that somebody else is pulling
the strings
um that tends to be the type of goal
that we will procrastinate on right it
lacks meaning yeah right and and so
there's a number of different reasons
for that we don't have that that sense
of meaning or accomplishment and that's
you know and and there can also be if
someone else is controlling that goal
there can be fear of disappointing them
or fear you know so it elicits all those
emotions whereas when it's something we
have a sense of control we take
ownership over that goal yeah right it
now becomes immediately meaningful
um and the one thing I didn't say about
the meaning making before so yeah sure
you know Finding meaning in the goals
works but one of the reasons that that
CeCe found it worked in her study was it
actually reduced those challenging
negative emotions so it reduces negative
emotions and I think the other reason it
works too is it doesn't now it doesn't
make them all go away I want to make
that really clear so finding meaning
isn't going to make you feel like oh
there's no negative feelings I have
about those tasks no those negative
feelings are still going to be there but
now they have context
now if I struggle with this emotion it's
important it's meaningful it's part of
this bigger picture of these larger
goals that I want to accomplish and so
somehow when we have the context for
those negative motions as being part of
a bigger picture it's okay to work
through them we're less likely to want
to disengage from them because now
there's a purpose to them yeah it's I
think it's when we have negative
emotions that don't have a purpose it's
just I don't want to feel this put it
aside but now oh that negative motion
has a purpose it's telling me I'm
learning it's telling me I'm becoming
stronger it's telling me I'm becoming
better at what I'm doing
then we're more inclined to want to
engage with that and find a way to work
through it rather than put it aside and
procrastinate fantastic
um is there any evidence that that our
environment has a role when it comes to
combating procrastination
yes um and I think here this is what I
was saying earlier about sort of
distractions and things that facilitate
procrastination right um and so you know
you hear a lot of talk about digital
distractions and environments that
aren't you know properly set up to work
and productivity they can be distracting
um the reason that you know what I call
I call these procrastinogenic
environments you know kind of like the
obesogenic environment right with all
the fast food the procrastinogenic
environment is one where there's tons of
you know digital distractions and
technology and all kinds of things that
are going to pull your focus away from
the tasks that you have to work on
um and because at or offer a pleasurable
alternative because what those types of
environments do first of all again
you've got a difficult task so it's not
you know motions is Ground Zero there
but
when now whether you continue to focus
on grappling through those difficult
emotions you may be finding some meaning
or something else or put it aside to do
something more fun is going to be driven
more by the environment because what
happens with these cues and environment
these social cues social media phone
banging whatever you can check the
latest message you know right
um and what that does is it offers
it focuses you on the goal of managing
your emotions right and so right I can
feel better by going to check my social
media I can feel better you know if
you're working from home and you like
baking when you're working in the
kitchen oh why not go bake some cookies
you know I mean so all of these things
in the environment they they Prime
our short-term goals of mood management
rather than priming the long-term goals
so if you want to set up an environment
that's going to be less procrastinogenic
you've got to remove all these other
things that would be pleasurable and
would facilitate you
disengaging from that task or avoiding
the task to find some immediate mood and
maybe help find meaning so putting
meaningful symbols of that task that
you're working on is a big report or a
book put things around you surround
yourself with things that that trigger
that meaning that make you think and
contemplate the meaningfulness to
yourself and to other people like why it
is that you're doing this thing and
that's going to help you sort of drive
through without you know and again
reducing those those distractions that
are going to pull you off task and and
make you say oh no my goal is to feel
good right now no no your goal is to get
this thing done yeah
yeah one of the one of the um
unreasonably effective techniques that
my brother used when he was doing his he
was applying to study maths at Oxford
and there's a lot of practice papers he
had to do so he just changed his like
computer wallpaper to be a photo of
Oxford and like every time you turn this
computer on he'd be like right let's go
like that made it more me I guess made
it made it more meaningful yeah yeah
yeah he's evoking the meaning of that
larger task and that so that's what you
what you want to do
um is there any role in positive
self-talk or affirmations which are
often used as like a way of combating
negative emotions to deal with
procrastination I guess it depends on
how they're targeted
um you know and that's not something
that's really been studied much yeah
um per se
um I mean I would speculate here just
say you know
it depends on what they're dealing with
you know so are those affirmations if
you're just layering over some
positivity on tops of negativity well
then you you know you it doesn't it's
not going to certainly going to do
anything because you're not addressing
um so if it's if something that is
specifically targeting those negative
emotions that you have so maybe it's you
know around fear if you're a failure or
you know getting it perfect or
displeasing somebody if it's some sort
of positive slot that's that that
tackles that specifically that might be
useful
okay but again there's not been any
studies that have necessarily looked at
that that's useful to know
um I think that covers all of our bases
um any any other sort of cures or
treatments for procrastination or
mitigating strategies that we've not yet
covered that comes in mind I mean we
didn't we didn't get into the whole
future self part of things the whole
like superhero thing yeah I mean there
has been some strategies as just if you
people prone to procrastination tend to
have a weaker relationship with their
future self weaker as in um they don't
feel that close to them they feel like
they're a stranger which is why it's
easy to put them on a pedestal and think
they're a superhero because it's no
longer like them anymore right yeah
um and most of us have difficulty
especially for our future selves of
connecting with them some people are
very good at doing that though the
people prone to procrastination because
their focus is so much on the now have
some difficulty with that and and it's a
I mean I didn't get into that Dynamic
but I think about if you're stressed
about a task if you're feeling negative
emotions around the task right you're
activating sort of you know the
sympathetic nervous system the stress
response the amygdala that detection
everything is focusing your attention to
the now yeah it's not focusing it to the
Future you need to be in a positive
state to be able to think abstractly and
think about the future yeah um and so
it's a very Vicious Circle there and
this is why we see the people prone to
procrastination and and this has
actually been shown in fmri studies scan
so the brain showed that people who
chronically procrastinate have deficits
in two areas of the brain one having to
do with future oriented thinking the
other having to do with motion
regulation right and it's because it's a
dance between the two of them right
you're more stressed you're thinking
about them now which means you're not
thinking about the future you're not
thinking about the future then you know
yeah so it comes down to the emotion
thing
um I guess
um uh the broaden and build Theory yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah Frederickson so
that's engaging positive motions meaning
making does that oh yeah yeah that's
that broadening build is like the core
piece of evidence that's like backing up
my whole thesis for this book yeah what
what because But but so what that does
is you're engaging the parasympathetic
nervous system which helps quiesce the
sympathetic nervous system which has us
you know running around stressed and
just focusing on you know rushing and
yeah just trying to deal with immediate
threats um and yeah there's a few things
that you you need to do to be able to
engage that system breathing yeah yeah
and one thing I didn't talk about is
mindfulness actually
um we did um publish with some Iranian
colleagues a paper this year where we
showed for student procrastinators
um an eight week course of mindfulness
training actually significantly reduced
their procrastination
because mindfulness is a way of managing
emotions right yeah yeah so um and then
people earlier I we did a study showing
the people who chronically procrastinate
tend to not engage in mindfulness-based
practices and tend to score lower on
these self-report measures of
mindfulness so that and that's very much
highly related to the self-compassion
again but any thing where that manages
emotions
um is going to be effective there okay
yeah I mean I think that's a great place
to end this uh Professor fuchsia thank
you so much um if someone has gotten to
the end of this conversation and they're
like oh you know I really want to find
out more can you recommend any resources
yours or anyone else's that would be a
good kind of starting point or next
place to go to after this conversation
to help people struggling with
procrastination yeah so um I put
together
um last year a self-help book on
procrastination that um goes into a lot
more detail on some of the things I
touched upon today
um it's basically quite simply called
procrastination what it is why it's a
problem and what you can do about it
it's published by APA Publishers life
Tools in print
and each chapter I've got exercises that
you can go through to sort of test
yourself on some of the concepts and
actually start to sort of probe some of
the emotions and start trying to put
some of the techniques I've talked about
into practice okay brilliant and we'll
put links to that and also your website
and everything down in the video
description and in the show notes so
people can feel free to have a browse
around if they if they would like sounds
great all right thank you so much for
coming on no thank you for having me all
right so that's it for this week's
episode of Deep dive thank you so much
for watching or listening all the links
and resources that we mentioned in the
podcast are going to be linked down in
the video description or in the show
notes depending on where you're watching
or listening to this if you're listening
to this on a podcast platform then do
please leave us a review on the iTunes
Store it really helps other people
discover the podcast or if you're
watching this in full HD or 4k on
YouTube then you can leave a comment
down below and ask any questions or any
insights or any thoughts about the
episode that would be awesome and if you
enjoyed this episode you might like to
check out this episode here as well
which links in with some of the stuff
that we talked about in the episode so
thanks for watching uh do hit the
Subscribe button if you aren't already
and I'll see you next time bye